[Music]
from the brothers who went from talented
to terrible faster than you can say
which house key comes to see audiences
demanded then sort of God then once
everyone had moved on with their lives
got again anyway Dumb and Dumber to
revisit the buddy comedy that's aged
about as well as Jeff Daniels face as
you follow two idiots on a quest to
deliver a mysterious package to a
beautiful girl again
Samsonite I persuade off only this time
it's so crushingly horrible our word is
our bond James Bond the goofballs you
used to love when you were 10 or 13 are
back and dumber than ever but now
they're also all unlikable sexist racist
and bizarrely mean-spirited we love you
heavy do you love him long time look any
doctor that always cracks me up
sure doctor doing the laundry maybe am i
right both of um if you liked the first
one this one is really gonna bum you out
now the Jim Carrey's comedy career is
dangling by a thread get ready to feel
uncomfortable as he does everything
short of drop to his knees and beg you
to laugh at him which you won't since he
spends the movie creepily trying to bang
a girl decades younger than him kind of
like real life this is a message for
Emma Stone far were a lot younger I
would marry sex
so this is what rock bottom feels like
jokes are never as funny the second time
around but that won't stop them from
dusting off the Binaca Spray gag the
most annoying sound in the world you
want to hear the second most annoying
sound in the world the mud cuts bad io
u--'s we write an IOU and I'm gonna
leave the plank I like it a lot are
lorica are lost dead birds and lloyd
having a fantasy about beating up asian
people then hooking up with a girl who
turns into the front of the truck there
is probably more than I missed get ready
for a script that feels like it was
written in 98 and kept in the shoe box
until Jim Carrey's career took a dive
full of dated pop-culture references
that no one bothered to update what they
say in Jerry Maguire Titanic and current
pop culture references that aren't gonna
age well so right along with Harry and
Lloyd in a movie so bad you won't even
look up from your phone when you have
watch it on cable when the only fun
moment is Rob riggles body pains and the
only good parts are when the credits
show clips from the first movie did they
get worse or did I just get older
she was rumored to be a Titanic [ __ ]
that's a lie Freda never stepped foot on
the Titanic
nah they definitely got worse story
farts
puh incest that means I'm very weak
almost BP spit snide more farts period
blood animal farts and vagina dust
[Music]
grown-ups too as if this movie wasn't
depressing enough can you believe that
guilt trip to Bill Murray to cameo in
that hazmat suit I'll bet it wasn't be
sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers biscuits and gravy derp derp
derpity derp did you just double dip
that chip bite my shiny metal ass
tonight we dine in Hell oh wait they
close at 6:00
okay how about Mickey D's finagle my
bagel
[Music]